Vsauce Kevin here a robot opened a door
why did tens of millions of people watch
this
why is opening a door a big deal well
just five years ago there was a big
Robotics Competition and only one team
nailed the door opening challenge
hitting robots to perform common human
tasks was the central feature of the
DARPA Robotics Challenge a competition
sponsored by the US Department of
Defense that challenged robots to
perform in emergency and search and
rescue settings in 2013 a team from
Florida Institute for human and machine
cognition was the only one of 16
competitors to earn a perfect score on
the door opening tasks and many of the
two-legged humanoid BOTS fell on their
face just five years later the
four-legged well-balanced Austin
Dynamics spot mate is capable of
sneaking into your bedroom as you sleep
so for now four legs are better than two
for door opening robots so why did this
go viral it seems kind of creepy to some
people for robots to bypass the
human-made barriers of doors and the
reason that opening a door has been
difficult for robots to do is because of
the moravec paradox basically that
high-level reasoning like computing math
equations doesn't require much
computational power but low-level
reasoning like walking on a sandy beach
or opening doors requires a ton of
computational resources so things that
humans are able to do without thinking
biological skills that have been refined
over millions of years are really hard
to get robots to do and things we've
developed more recently like playing
chess are a lot easier so that's that
but that's not all because this is mine
[Music]
the Dumbo octopus got its name because
its fins resemble the Disney characters
big ears and for the first time we've
seen that baby Dumbo
octopuses are actually born as tiny
adults Tim shank of the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution in
Massachusetts used a remote operated
vehicle over a mile below the ocean
surface to collect samples of what
appeared to be egg cases and then one
hatched when the baby octopod emerged
and at all the characteristics of an
adult an MRI confirmed that from the
outside features to the central nervous
system this rare baby Dumbo was fully
formed and ready to go he probably grew
to be about 10 inches long and danced
around like this
we know from mind blow 116 that rats are
heroes who can detect landmines and
diseases but they're also all-around
nice folks researchers at the University
of st. Andrews found that rats who have
had something nice done for them
returned the favor
rats trade food and grooming services
and it's shedding light on our built-in
instinctual responses to kindness so
next time someone calls you a dirty rat
say thank you I am kind and I do need a
bath
Israeli Ramon Utz have returned safely
from a four-day mission on Mars d Mars
just like high seas in Hawaii the Mars
simulation I visited from my planet
behind your eyes video the desert Mars
analog remote station in the Negev
desert simulates the arid desolate
environment of the Red Planet inside the
mock - ramon crater researchers can
undergo the daily routine of life on
mars and deal with its serious
limitations experiments from the first
mission included determining the optimal
materials for 3d printing on mars and a
psychological study of the correlation
between stress and language variability
in writing it turns out that research
subjects write less and use a smaller
vocabulary when they're under stress so
the first d Mars simulation is helping
to show how our communication changes
when our environment changes the main
takeaway I had from the lava knots I
interviewed in Hawaii is that developing
technology to live on Mars will help us
better understand and live on earth
which seems good and smell a word from
1981 nothing we wanna watch on TV
tonight but we're still gonna watch
something great with our RCA videodisc
player and video discs just flip a
switch and on our TV we see airplanes or
the Pink Panther The Godfather of grease
Muppets monsters Mickey mash and 100
more starting as low as $15
and the beer cost less than 500 put it
this way we're watching a great movie
and you're watching
[Music]
a new inkjet bio printing technique uses
common cells and molecules found in
biological tissue to create lifelike
tissue in the lab researchers at Queen
Mary University of London are using
droplet printing to assemble bio
fabricated structures that can make
testing drugs or research and cancer
growth easier and the method utilizes
molecular self-assembly that builds
microscopic structures like Lego African
MonaVie Leanne's frequently raid termite
colonies and they never leave a wounded
friend behind research published in the
Proceedings of the Royal Society beef
shows that after intense termite battles
in which limbs are bitten off and the
ants are gravely wounded they send
pheromone signals as a cry for help
ants come to the rescue by picking up
their wounded carrying them home and
then engaging in intense licking
sessions that prevent infection until
the wound is healed the ants have a
two-step process that determines who can
be saved and who can't
the mortally wounded are passed over
while the lightly wounded are saved one
model calculates that reducing the
mortality rate in termite battles allows
the ants have colonies up to 29 percent
larger than if they continually lost
soldiers and they demonstrate to us that
even insects can show compassion to come
up with new breakthroughs in science and
technology
you can't just memorize formulas you
have to learn how to think through
complex problems brilliants interactive
problems are a great way for you to
really understand math and science if
everything from 2d geometry to math of
poker or this one I really like on
physics of the everyday this crime
course allows you to use the physics of
a bike track to solve a murder which way
did the killer go so click the link at
the top of this video's description to
get 20% off your annual subscription
your brain will thank you now I'm gonna
leave you with a video telephone concept
for shopping over long distances
in 1961 and as always thanks for
watching these are the shapes of the
future tools for communication now being
forged and tested against tomorrow's
unfolding needs not yet
but sooner than you may realize and some
of what's on the drawing boards may be a
little out of this world and now maybe
show you one of our newest models
designed by Howard of Hong Kong
notice the dramatically shaped yellow I
don't know do you have it in green
certainly here it is yes fine that's it
I'll take it please send it out to me
here's my credit card
oh and don't forget the striped
pillowcases no we won't thank you bye
there's an old saying the more things
change the more they stay the same
[Music]